e pronto pronto papa ciao scusa però non
posso parlare adesso perché sto entrando
in una riunione si è arrivato il
telefono muovo bene son contento grazie
fa le foto meglio della macchina
fotografica
sì io non posso parlare lo passano in
una riunione si vabbè mandami se va bene
mandavi i messaggi che ti rispondo
vocale ciao scusa e non posso non può
grazie ciao sì la riunione ciao ciao
scusate però ha cambiato il telefono
papa e non riuscivo a allora visto che
mi hanno chiamato e quindi magari mi
manderà qualche qualche messaggio ecco
ha iniziato papa si ciao
beh questa me la ricordo questa foto
1959 un un ingegnere meccanico
elettronico oggi si chiamerebbe
meccatronico indiano degli anni sessanta
quindi che poi sarebbe arrivato in
italia per per fare
la carriera e quindi per il come
direttore di una industria meccanica
beh sono anni fantastici quali devo dire
che per il lavoro che faccio
quello è un ventennio incredibile per lo
spazio anche perché da pochissimo era
iniziata la corsa per lo spazio europa
ti ricordi e dirà ecco bravo poi hai
trovato l'articolo originale hai trovato
l'articolo originale della united press
che di che che dichiara di quando lo
sputnik era stato lanciato quindi quello
avviato la corsa per lo spazio un
ventennio fantastico sono nate cose
incredibili
il laser il cd le valvole cardiache
il cuore artificiale beh praticamente
alla fine anche tu papà cose inaspettate
bellissime dai città meno è una di
quelle cose che ti son capitate in quel
ventennio bellissimo e inaspettato
ecco magari non pensavo questo però sì
mi ricordo il ricordo perché ce l'ha
raccontato tantissime volte la tua
partecipazione come ospite straniero in
caso di emergenza a sette voci
mi ricordo che ci raccontavi ci racconti
ancora adesso di quando tu suonabili il
banjo thai sokoto non ho mai capito
perché ad essere un nome giapponese a
uno strumento indiano comunque e poi tra
l'altro mi dicevi anche che tucson a v
con lo strumento insieme a un'orchestra
mi raccontavi anche di quanto fosse
giovane pippo baudo di quanto fosse
bravo anche maestro a seguire con
l'orchestra mi ricordo mai come si
chiama quel maestro dall'altro ecco
questo l'abbiamo sentito veramente un
sacco di volte a casa mi ricordo anzi
pino calvi che mi dicevi era bravissimo
perché riusciva a tenere in mano tutta
un'orchestra a ok va bene il tuo
preferito da enrico simonetti se anche
questo vuole sempre detto perché enrico
simonetti ti diceva che lui con la sua
orchestra e tu quel tuo banjo thai
sopporto riuscivate a unire il passato e
il futuro vivendo il presente
sì però mentre tu andavo in studio a
registrare il martedì e il venerdì
perché andata in onda la domenica a
mezzogiorno e la sera guarda che tutto
il mondo mentre tu correvi in cui a dire
se non li tutto il mondo correva per
l'esplorazione correva verso verso lo
spazio in quel ventennio bravo l'apollo
beh lo sai che quel 20 luglio del 69 900
milioni di persone erano incollati
davanti alla televisione
un po perché era un evento mondiale e un
po perché dietro non si vedeva niente ma
erano incollati davanti alla televisione
e tra adduce ri
tu c'eri però guarda di quel ventennio
lì la cosa bellissima era quello che
spingeva l'uomo essere curioso l'uomo
esploratore l'esplorazione dello spazio
quindi la curiosità è in qualche modo è
ok va bene papà possiamo identificare
quel ventennio come curiosity driven
quindi la curiosità ha guidato l'uomo
nelle sue delle sue scoperte e beh devo
dire che alla fine è una cosa ma cose
normali
questa è la punta me la ricordo ci siamo
trasferiti negli stati uniti a san
francisco tutto il mondo le andare a san
francisco
qui sei tu e lo zio mi pare quello con
la destra a quello a destra perché non
avevo mai avuto i capelli come lo zio
però e san francisco e tutto il mondo si
spostava lì già si vedeva l'innovazione
nasce la silicon valley cominciava già a
nascere in quel a produrre delle cose
particolari e a nascere in quel
ventennio
io mi ricordo che l'innovazione si
vedeva dappertutto ti ricordi papa il
primo giorno di scuola quando sono
tornato e andavo a scuola auckland ti
ricordi che ti racconta dell'innovazione
stratosferica che avevo visto in quella
scuola si o il carretto da trascinare
per andare a far la merenda da
trascinare avere dentro la scatoletta le
scatolette del latte per tutti i
compagni per me erano innovazione
fantastiche però è in verità in verità
le innovazioni nascevano un po da altre
da altre parti
in laboratori piuttosto che in altri
nelle aziende eccetera è pesato il
computer di cellulare il floppy disk i
processori eccetera eccetera
beh tutte cose devo dire super super
fantastiche alla fine erano cose va beh
ok allora rubami la scena la qualità
della vita sì perché erano tecnologie
che utilizzavano in quel ventennio tutte
le innovazioni possibile per migliorare
la qualità della vita
questo capitava anche nel settore dello
spazio tantissime tecnologie in quel
ventennio utilizzate nello spazio
venivano applicate a terra il velcro il
materiale termoresistenti per le pentole
i microprocessori e quindi i device i
dispositivi portatili
il latte in polvere quindi delle cose
che ovviamente è bello shuttle dai papà
in quel ventennio ci sono state le più
il più alto numero di concentrazione di
missione dello shop
lo shuttle guardava al futuro e ci
faceva capire come le tecnologie
avrebbero in qualche modo condizionato
il nostro futuro
si vabbè to air è occupato al futuro ii
proprio mettere questa foto qua io sono
quello senza gonna e tra l'altro è però
va bene comunque aiuto ma ho mai chiesto
vero e il futuro perché tu beh ok tu
pensavi a questo perché tu guardavi
fornari avanti guardavi oltre diciamo
che guardava al futuro
anche questo non c'era bisogno di dirlo
perché sono qua e riunione allora
mettiamola così papà io guardavo questo
perché mi stavo preparando il lavoro che
faccio adesso a portare a tecnologia dà
spazio a terra e poi tra l'altro il
termine robot deriva da una parola ceca
che si chiama robota usata per la più
volte nel 1920
un'opera teatrale giro buoni versailles
di rossum è però i robot adesso sono
ormai diventati quasi di uso di dominio
comune perché li troviamo nell'industria
troviamo nel settore della salute
ritroviamo nel quotidiano nostro a casa
i robot quindi quindi dai dai
alla fine io stavo in qualche modo
cercando di anticipare il il futuro e la
casa allora me la ricordo perché in
effetti per un ingegnere meccanico
elettrico degli anni sessanta ritornare
in italia dopo gli stati uniti e fare la
sua prima casa insieme alla moglie
beh è stata una cosa fantastica mi
ricordo quando il fatto questa foto qua
tra l'altro poi in quel ventennio lì si
è riuscito anche ad alzarla di due piani
quindi è una bellissima la caserma però
mentre tu costruirvi la tua casa
il resto del mondo papa stava costruendo
la casa nello spazio stava costruendo
una cosa incredibile
bravo questa la stazione spaziale
internazionale ha tra l'altro papa lo
sai che più della metà del volume
abitabile la sezione spettante nazionale
è fatto in italia
comunque nel ventennio precedente
nessuno avrebbe immaginato che molti
paesi della terra si fossero messi
insieme per creare che cosa un enorme
laboratorio grande come una skin in
campo di calcio in orbita a 400 e più
avanti distanza dalla terra e ogni
viaggio a 27 mila chilometri all'ora
quindi di fatto è una grandissima si ok
un avamposto questa foto mi fa venire in
mente un po l'avamposto è l'unico va un
posto che abbiamo noi nello spazio oddio
seconda della terminologia delle
dimensioni spaziali e molto molto vicino
a noi però per noi un avamposto per noi
è come dire vediamo se questa quale hpc
papa
spazio ultima frontiera per arrivare là
dove nessun uomo è giunto prima e te la
ricordi papa questa qui papa non era
questo e non era questo qui tra l'altro
però questo vabbè dai che mi hai mandato
questo in effetti dava un po l'idea di
come questa serie è stata pensata nel 73
dava l'idea di come vent'anni dopo si
vedeva già la luna colonizzata beh
quella dalla frontiera però sai e nel 50
anni dopo l'allunaggio 12 astronauti
sono stati sulla luna 12 azionati hanno
camminato sulla luna e hanno camminato
per un totale di meno di 24 ore
di fatto non ci siamo ancora stati
tantissimo in maniera permanente sulla
luna quindi per me questa è un po la
nostra frontiera nella nostra frontiera
beh questa è la frontiera dello spazio
ma in quel ventennio quello che si stava
cominciando a sviluppare era la
frontiera delle tecnologie le tecnologie
di frontiera che poi avrebbero dato in
qualche modo luogo bravo lo so se sto
facendo io o se stai ma non ultimi
messaggi a questo tour però la new
economy tecnologie di frontiera che in
qualche modo avrebbero pervaso la nostra
vita quotidiana come un po capitava
anche nei ventenni precedenti lo
smartphone la stampa 3d
gli oggetti connessi i satelliti noi
oggi senza i satelliti papa non
riusciremmo veramente a muoverci a fare
nulla perché il posizionamento
satellitare l'immagine servizio né della
terra quindi diciamo è assolutamente
basilare beh ti devo dire che ti ricordi
una volta ne abbiamo parlato
gli avevo mandato un'immagine che questo
ventennio qua il ventennio della s
dell'adozione delle tecnologie la
rapidità anacoreti ricordi questo qui
questo praticamente ne avevamo parlato
una volta ecco però
il tempo molto breve le tecnologie hanno
un'adozione molto repentina molto rapida
quindi la velocità
questa è la cosa più più importante e
forse questa volta ti anticipo io da
curiosi di driven forse siamo passati ha
anticipato tu a technology driven quindi
in qualche modo siamo riusciti a portare
la tecnologia al centro dell'attenzione
beh in qualche modo diciamo che ci siamo
arrivati
sì ci stiamo pensando e però vediamo un
pochettino che cosa che cosa fare beh
qualcuno dice che tra vent'anni noi
saremo su marte si in effetti effetti
ragione va però guala secondo me la cosa
più affascinante sarà il percorso che
faremo e ci arriveremo o no su marte
il percorso lo sviluppo delle scienze la
ricerca scientifica
le nuove tecnologie quella sera la parte
più importante che noi dovremmo in
qualche modo considerare come il vero il
vero viaggio la vera colonizzazione
no è tranquillo scusa papa avete fatto
questa casa barra caserma ma tu e la
mamma con tanta fatica no no la casa
della casa rimane dai quella poi sai la
casa è una diretta
abbiamo è un asset quello quello rimane
quindi a chi dice di questa casa
beh in effetti si è l'unica cosa che ci
rimane questa è l'unica cosa che abbiamo
di casa conosciuta quindi secondo me il
prossimo ventennio sostenibilità sarà la
parola adatta la sostenibilità
energetica alimentare sociale climatica
quindi usare le tecnologie e la scienza
che lei svilupperemo in questo percorso
fantastico nei prossimi 20 anni
per affrontare queste sfide la sfida
della sostenibilità altrimenti cadremmo
veramente in un periodo buio e cupo beh
ok dai questa volta forse c hai
azzeccato anche perché tra l'altro non
so se cosa hai fatto per caso ma lo sai
che questo film papa è ambientato in che
periodo nel novembre 2000 e 19 oggi è
quindi sostenibilità
ok ma guarda te una domanda interessante
però guarda riprendo quel film in verità
io il 2000 39 non lo immagino perché non
riesco perché ho visto che il futuro in
qualche modo ha superato anche la
scienza la fantascienza e la fantasia
quel film che citato prima ad esempio
non aveva nessun tipo di riferimento a
internet
se hai notato in quel film tra l'altro
telefonavano ancora da una cabina
telefonica
quindi non c'è lo smartphone quindi sarà
sicuramente qualcosa di bellissimo e di
e di fantastico quindi beh sì è vero
arriva molto più velocemente beh tu hai
visto
adesso che ci penso tu hai visto tre
ventenni di innovazione e di tecnologia
però guarda ti dirò secondo me questo
prossimo ventennio la velocità ce l'avrà
ma avrà un altro fattore
l'accelerazione l'accelerazione col
quale noi svilupperemo le innovazioni
che basate sulla tecnologia e la scienza
che svilupperemo di noi nei prossimi 20
anni ci permetteranno in qualche modo di
affrontare le nostre le nostre sfide e
in qualche modo a ok tu hai preso quello
che
beh in effetti è vero in effetti è vero
questa curva verrà modificata in questo
modo perché l'accelerazione ci permette
di rendere o per fortuna o purtroppo
molto più veloce
l'adozione delle tecnologie e lo
sviluppo delle tecnologie stesse quindi
sì devo dire che alla fine forse questo
questo capiterà non so se è un bene o un
male perché velocità e accelerazione
allora io mi ricordo quando è portata a
casa e non so perché hai citato questa
cosa però la centro di sette verde in
via la satta la tua prima macchina nuova
beh ma la ricorda con la propria casa in
verità non mi ricordo il concetto di
velocità e accelerazione associato a
questa macchina è però forse era perché
guidava la mamma può essere sì vabbé ok
è facile per te un ingegnere meccanico
elettrico degli anni sessanta non è nato
con internet non è nato poi social non è
nato con lo smartphone in mano e quindi
devo dire che è molto molto facile dire
dire così si si certo certo ah beh
questo assolutamente questo diciamo
questa è la navata e tutti adesso mi
dici cosa c'entra la foto di famiglia è
quello dei nostri antenati e così via
al papa è quello a destra seduto diciamo
lo vedete se usato sulla sulla destra mi
dice cosa c'entrava fa questa questa
fotogramma che alla fine si certo
assolutamente tutto molto molto molto
vero però è facile tu lo fai veramente
veramente molto molto facile si scusa tu
scusa non volevo e meritano non saprei
senti comincia tu perché non lo so tu
che hai visto tre ventenni di
innovazioni mi dici quali sono i settori
dove la tecnologia del futuro tecnologia
del prossimo ventennio avrà più impatto
ok è tutto devo dire estremamente
condivisibile sì mi dici tu come ti stai
preparando questo ventennio emozionante
eccitante di tecnologie ed innovazioni e
profondo è è un concetto profondo questo
qui è veramente un concetto profondo
quasi come lo spazio era papa devo dire
che sì si guarda se devo dirti io quello
che penso nel prossimo ventennio
beh ti dirò l'importanza sarà
contaminare le tecnologie l'importanza
sarà mettere insieme fertilizzare
tecnologie anche il nostro ambito
tecnologie spazio con ambiti non spazio
fare in modo che ci sia la commistione
fare in modo che si creino nuove scienze
come nell'ultimo ventennio si sono
create la bioingegneria la
bioinformatica mettere insieme tutto ma
il fattore ips sarà l'accelerazione
l'accelerazione delle innovazioni per
fare in modo che si possa affrontare
tutti insieme la sfida globale quindi sì
direi con questi questi due concetti
certo un futuro veloce accelerato come
come un treno
essi però senza binari e magari con
libertà di movimento però velocità e
accelerazione quindi susa papa a 26
ok va bene stavo pensando perché abbiamo
dato questa foto è
oh oh ragazzi mi son dimenticato di
coppa quest'anno fa 80 anni sta venendo
qui quella foto che ha mandato in
effetti in effetti è vero io non ho
ancora pensato che cosa fargli come come
regalo mi fate un favore visto che sono
l'ultimo speaker posso anche mi posso
fare un video se gli facciamo al mio tre
auguri papà perché per me non glielo
scusate perchè se posso allora al miu
miu 3 auguri papà 123
grandi grandi grazie grazie ad esso
romanzo glielo mando no no no glielo
vado bene adesso lavora lavora visto
quindi vi prego prego prego prego dunque
bella riunione sul futuro io sul futuro
stiamo ma siamo in chiusura e stiamo
stiamo chiudendo comunque grazie stato
grazie grazie
saluta tutti anche da parte mia e già
che se li ricorda tutti di rimanere
curiosi verso le tecnologie di pensare
in maniera è aperta di farsi pro
terminare per migliorare la qualità
della vita e del nostro unico pianeta
io sono solo un ingegnere meccanico ed
elettrico di anni 60 ciao ciao park
grazie grazie grazie mille
grazie alle grazie beh questa è una foto
in effetti è vero tre generazioni
il papa il figlio e il nipote
senti papà io in verità non ho l'ho
chiesta come enrico simonetti quindi non
posso suonare
però in effetti lui aveva ragione quando
diceva che il tuo belgio riusciva a
unire il passato con il futuro vivendo
il presente
ti ho fatto una sorpresa
[Musica]
lo fa
dell'hip hop
l'importante venturo vivendo tutti e due
il presente
papà ti voglio bene
[Applauso]